okay well I gather we are ready to get
started
so let's launch they so I realize this
is the 26th time that I have opened one
of our technology conferences I think
the the first time was was this one here
long long ago in in Redwood City in 1990
but now is actually a quite amazing time
for us we've been we've been kind of at
all of this for about 30 years now
so we've we've been we've been at all of
this for for close to thirty years now
and now is really a very exciting time
for us because a lot of things that
we've been building for much of those
thirty years are finally coming together
and making really exciting things
possible i it's sort of amazing that the
26th time of doing this how can there be
anything new to say and I realize that
this year I have more new to say than
I've ever had before in any previous
year so I'm I'm going to go fairly fast
I'm going to talk about a bunch of
different things
almost everything I'll talk about will
be covered in some other talk probably
better than then that I'd be able to
cover it but the the I want to just go
over a few of the sort of general things
that are going on some of the big
picture of what's happening so I'll
start with them with kind of the very
specific stuff and then I'll go to more
general kinds of things so let's start
with with specifics so at the end of
last week version ten point three was
released and that's kind of a a word
cloud summary of what's in version ten
point three to me it's rather impressive
because version 10.2 was released only
90 days earlier so this is kind of what
what came to the end of the R&D pipeline
during that 90 day period we've been
really accelerating in terms of the
kinds of Rd that we can do I think we've
by this point got very good processes
for for making R&D happen that
building that really make use of the
automation that we've built in in our
technology stack this is at this point
we are averaging about one new function
per day and which I consider to be
rather impressive
that-that-that's I'll talk about some of
the some of what's been going on in 10.3
this was the 10.2 word cloud that came
out 90 days earlier it's if you look at
the overall plot that's some the number
of new functions as a function of time
since since Mathematica was first
released in 1988 you can see this major
inflection point at version 5 back here
all sorts of things were going on then
particularly this is the time when we
really really started to emphasize using
sort of the automation that we'd built
in our technology and and opened up all
sorts of things to to allow this kind of
growth well so it's it's actually it's
I'm sort of proud of all of all of this
continued growth over this long period
of time it's it's great that we've been
able to keep building things for this
long it's it's sort of I think a
consequence of sort of principles that
we've had both in terms of the
technology we built and in terms of the
the company that we've built it's it's
something where it's it's some building
a private company like ours that's
intended to just keep doing interesting
things for forever is something that has
not been very fashionable in the
technology world I think it's actually
coming back into fashion now which is
always nice the but it's been it's been
a great thing for us because we've been
able to just just keep building things
for all these years be doing both sort
of a mixture of systemic developments at
any given time and and new stuff it's
very easy to end up with a situation
where you're you're you know developing
the things that you have been developing
for a long time and never get to do
anything new we have sort of a portfolio
approach where we're both continuing our
mainstream developments and adding lots
of lots of new stuff
well okay so let's talk about the that's
why might as well talk about version ten
point three why not this is as I say the
last 90 days of of things that have been
done so let's let's take a look at a few
specific things here this is a there's a
list of new functions in version ten
point three for those of you I'm going
to this is so that we're going to start
in the specific and then we're going to
build up to the the bigger picture here
but let's sum let's start off looking at
some things in in ten point three where
can we start well we can um let's let's
let's start with something let's start
with something very specific where we
bring up ten point three here the let's
let's take a look for example there's a
lot of kind of mathy stuff down here how
about some I actually have never tried
this okay so I get to try this for the
first time here so we have Gaussian
orthogonal matrix distribution and let's
say we have a 10 by 10 matrix and let's
say we have a random variate of that
type
we should get let's see we get a nice
matrix there that's good let's let's say
we do a matrix plot of that okay there's
a there's a matrix I don't know what
that looks like it's size 100 not very
exciting but what we can do now perhaps
is let's let's do something we've we've
worked on lots of kinds of random
processes and recent versions let's
let's look at this let's look at the
matrix property distribution of
eigenvalues for example of of some
matrix m where m is distributed
according to a gaussian orthogonal
matrix distribution of size 100 okay so
let's try this see if there's going to
work okay so let's say let's say we want
to make them let's say we take that and
we want to make a histogram of that
result so this is sort of interesting
let's see if this works what do I have
to do here oh I probably have to
I have to say I want to random variate
there um and I need to get rid of that
okay there we go so what what's what's
interesting about this this is a real
sort of deep use of symbolic computation
because what we're doing here is we're
representing we're saying this is a this
is a matrix M it's distributed according
to a Gaussian orthogonal distribution
and we're going to say let's let's work
out the distribution of the eigenvalues
of that matrix and that's just sample a
bunch of random variates of that kind
and make make a histogram out of those
so it's sort of interesting let's see if
we can do this I'm probably living
dangerously by trying to do something
that big that's a 25 million element
matrix that were sampling lots of times
well see whether it doesn't a thing so
this is so oh there we go
isn't that nice I think that makes a
semi-circle distribution as I recall the
so so this is sort of core development
and again a lot of the kind of
algorithmic mathematical development
that we're doing builds on many many
years decades now of previous
development to make possible that the
kinds of things we're doing now let's
let's try them let's try one other
example here let's say let's try is a
cute example so this is this is building
out some some of the things that we've
done in in differential equations so
here's a here's a polygon we've got
let's let's try to take that polygon and
use it as it so it's a this should be
let's just see what it looks like okay
it's an l-shaped polygon here let's try
and take that that l-shaped polygon and
let's say let's try and solve the
Laplace equation inside the region
corresponding to that l-shaped polygon
so we're just saying we're finding the
eigen this is solving an eigenvalue PDE
so it's saying solve the eigenvalue PDE
for laplacian where the de richelieu
boundary condition that says this
function is equal to 0 here where XY is
is an element of el ok so let's see what
happens if
do this okay so now what we've we should
have got now we asked it to find six
eigenvalues of that PDE in that region
so we've got a bunch of interpolating
functions here and now let's go ahead
and say let's make a well that's for
example let's make a contour plot of
each of those interpolation functions so
what we've done now is we've solved in
that rather tiny piece of code we've
solved the PDE in this region got the
first six I can values there let's see
we can maybe let's do instead of that
let's do plot 3d here and let's so let's
do we do this okay so now what we will
have got is the solution for the
eigenvalues the Laplace equation in an
l-shape region i guess this is a picture
made famous by a numerical software
package that that has long been around I
have actually no idea whether they got
it right which we should find that out
they said they these are the higher
eigen modes of of the same thing that
have now thanks to all of the things
that we've done in solving PDEs and
being able to do computational geometry
and all the kinds of algebraic analysis
that go into to being able to
efficiently solve p d--'s of this type
and being able to get successive eigen
functions and so on we're able to get
that now in a rather rather modest
number of lines of code and so on ok so
let's turn to something completely
different so this is this is a gun this
is stuff that arrived in the last 90
days for version ten point three let's
let's let's look at a completely
different thing that arrived so let's
say we look at this is some data here
this is anatomical data so for example
let's say I say I want to get the mesh
region corresponding to a human femur
there we go so now we've got a couple of
human femurs here we can take this and
this is now a we have this for what is
it 20 20 something thousand structures
in the human body and you can you can
take this and you can say for example I
could make me say take the area of that
geometrical thing or I could go ahead
and start solving PDE
on this female shape which is kind of
nice we can get let's try and try
something a more complicated structure
let's say let's take up well we've got
lots of properties of one of these
things if I say I may be living
dangerously here by doing this but let's
say I do something like this I can get
sort of a list of all the all the
properties that we know for this may
take a while and maybe a lot of stuff
here maybe this was a mistake
the I think this was a mistake I think I
think we have too much to - let's oh no
maybe not well okay let's let's go ahead
that look like they're about a hundred
different properties which include lots
of different detailed things about
detailed anatomical data about what
blood vessels come into the heart and so
on I should have picked a simpler
structure but here let's let's at least
just try and get some 3d graphics and we
can get some idea of what what level of
detail we have here there we go okay
there's a nice nice heart with lots of
different structures which one can take
apart and analyze and so on okay so
that's an another completely different
kind of thing let's let's try something
completely different again so so we
introduced a while ago a convenient term
function Wikipedia data which goes and
fetches for example text from Wikipedia
so for example I could like I took
there's the article about computers from
Wikipedia or not you know this is
something that I think came in in
version 10 point I lose track of this is
either ten point one or ten point two
you can just say take the text about the
article about computers from Wikipedia
and make a word cloud from the words in
that so there we go
I could also just take that article and
I could say let's let's let's just get
from the article that say text sentences
and then let's take the article and
let's get the first sentence from it
okay there we go
okay let's do something different with
that sentence let's say let's get that
first sentence there and let's say text
structure for that sentence is now some
new and 10.3 oh great this may take a
while maybe not there we go okay so this
is now a parse tree of that sentence I
could for example say let's take to take
that thing on line 24 and let's say
let's get a constituent graph from that
and now we'll have something which is
the the parse tree of that sentence
which we can then feed into our graph
system if we want to that's actually a
slightly complicated sentence well okay
and let's let's take that it's just just
for fun let's just take that graph and
just show let's make something like a
community graph plots probably gonna
make a big mess from this thing but okay
there we go that's it's not a
particularly useful thing to do for this
sentence but what's interesting is that
the the parse tree that we get is just a
graph structure that we can then
manipulate with using all the other
techniques that we have in in the system
okay other kinds of things we've got
some that were new in the last 90 days
let's see what other things well we've
got some that's let's look we have a
word list okay so we've got this word
list this is a list of common words in
English we have it we could let's say
for example we okay here's the thing
that we can do so we can start saying
let's ask for a word translation so
let's say the word hello and let's
translate it into all the languages we
can currently do okay
so there's a translation of the word
hello this is just this this particular
system is just for word-for-word
translation it's quite interesting to
see different kinds of words it's quite
a few languages there we can go ahead
another function that's new is
transliterate so we can say
transliterate that so if we do that most
languages we will have a a
transliteration into a kind of
romanization of these things into into
standard ASCII and so on so that's a
another kind of new thing it's kind of
kind of interesting to explore the sort
of world of linguistics with this I
don't think has ever been kind of a
we've been curating kind of as many
languages as we can and more will be
progressively added another I think we
had added in a
in a previous version things like just
the alphabet that's quite a useful thing
you know you can get the alphabet in and
all sorts of different different
languages and such like let's let's look
at another another kind of thing we have
so let's say another function is travel
directions so this is something where
we're basically taking the graph of the
street map of the world we have kind of
a version of the street map of the world
in in our cloud and so for example let's
say we could go let's do travel
directions I don't know from somewhere
in Montreal to let's be ambitious here
let's go Montreal - this may be a big
mistake but let's try this ok let's see
which one it that is Santiago Chile ok
so let's see whether we can do this so
this should be now computing from the
street map of the world it's it's
computing travel directions we can start
looking at those travel directions ok
total distance 9600 miles total time 12
days 7 hours etc we can ask it to show
us the travel path and now that will be
a ok so there we go
65,000 points on that path let's say we
can say Geographics of that now I should
be able to just show that travel path on
a map of the world there we go and I
think ok there's a ferry being taken but
it's quite impressive that we're able to
do this this computation from from this
graph and so on and get the results this
way this is happening on our there's not
happening locally on individual machines
is happening on a server of ours that
that has all of that Geographic data on
it ok so another thing that's that's new
as as you probably know we've long been
able to do things like you know take a
country for example and say what is the
population of that country a question is
to do sort of the inverse problem this
is something that's been possible and
wolf malphur for a while but now we're
adding capabilities in the language to
be able to do this and so we say let's
say we have an entity and it's a
country and let's say we want to take
who wants to get the five smallest
countries by population so we can say
and I can explain how this how this all
works we can say get an entity an entity
of type country the population is take
smallest to five and if I now say give
me an entity list that will explicitly
give me a list of the five countries
with the smallest population so just to
start explaining this is kind of a whole
pattern of how things work this is well
maybe I shouldn't explain this into much
detail right now this is this is a
function take smallest as a function
that for example if I say I don't know
range from 100 to 200 here take smallest
we'll take the five smallest this is a
so called this kind of an operator form
of take smallest one could just say take
smallest of of so range of 100 comma 200
will just make us some yeah it's just to
get that so this will this will just get
us this and now take smallest of that
comma 6 for example we'll get the 6
smallest entries there but there's also
a different form here where we can say
take smallest of 6 and then apply that
as an operator to what was on line 40
and get that this is kind of using a
generalization of that in inside the our
entity framework to basically be able to
do a lookup that says of all the
entities that we have so for example we
could have a specific entity here that's
a country and we could have the specific
country I don't know France or something
here this is now a way of saying of all
possible entities of type country find
the one whose population is is the where
you get the result of applying this
operator takes smallest to all of those
possible countries so there's a whole
new world of kind of ontology of
entities we've got some many millions of
entities in our system now we're able to
sort of build up more kind of composite
entities so for example a typical
example would be an
to the instance so an entity instance
might be something like you know what's
the what's this is this represents
France in the year 1950 and now we could
say I think we can just say let's get
the value entity value here for
population for France specifically in
the year 1950 so this is a way of taking
a taking an entity and making sort of a
sub instance of it for example a country
in a particular year or a particular
number of grams of some material all
those kinds of ways to make sort of sub
instances of things okay let me show you
some completely different kinds of
things that again arrived in in the last
90 days so another thing is something
called Form page so this this has to do
with deployment of things on in in the
cloud so for example let's say I say
well let's take an example here let's
sum let's say X is an animal and let's
say we want to get um let's just do a
simple thing here let's say we want to
have image of that so now what we can do
is we say cloud deploy of this form page
now we have had and what this should do
is to create in our cloud a page here
where we can say I don't know we can say
it woops that's bad misspelled let's
come on connect how it managed to figure
out that that was an otter even okay so
anyway the the the point of this is that
what we've got here is a thing that's
kind of if you wanted to build Wolfram
Alpha in with with our language this
would be kind of the way you would do it
this is a recycling kind of form page
what we've had in the past is form
functions where you where you have kind
of a let me show you that where you have
kind of a one-shot thing where you can
get get a sort of an app produced here
and oh great and you type it in and then
you just get one page back the new thing
in
form page which is just a real useful
capability is to be able to have a page
that say a recycling page where you can
do a computation get a result then do
another computation and so on okay so so
also in kind of the the world of 10.3
we've been we've been kind of
incrementally adding a lot of what one
of the things that we've been doing is
to sort of incrementally add different
capabilities to the language we have
kind of an internal project we call it
incremental language development
ILD and it's been sort of a continual
process of trying to polish and enhance
the the sort of core capabilities of the
language so there are very very
straightforward kinds of things like you
know there's a function palindrome queue
now that just tests whether things are
palindrome so I could say you know
select from the word list of English
words things which are palindromes and
then that's just kind of a one-liner
thing to find the palindromes in in
english functions like what one general
theme actually - some of these functions
is things that used to be kind of idioms
in the system we've tried to give
explicit names to so one very common
thing one does when one is writing code
is to say I want to print something out
but I want to get back the the thing
that I printed out so I can keep using
it somewhere else so there's now a
function called echo which will print
out print something out and return the
thing that it printed out so when you're
writing a piece of code it's convenient
to just be able to say I don't know
somewhere back up here let's find a
piece of code that we wrote to be able
to just say someplace here echo I don't
know we could put it in here we could
just say echo that and well how about
yeah okay you could say echo that and it
will echo that and then give us the the
result after it well that was a long and
silly thing to echo but but you get the
idea so so anyway that this sort of an
effort to to kind of progressively add
these kind of convenience functions one
of the things that
I when I was first designing Mathematica
now will from language long ago I had
the idea that that one should design
things so that one so that what had sort
of the most minimal set of primitives in
the language and that if some operations
were were done a lot well there will be
some idiom in the language what I
realized in more recent years is that if
there is an idiom something that people
commonly use in the language if there is
an obvious name for that piece of
functionality
she just create a function and give it
that name the reason that's a worthwhile
thing to do is that when you read a
piece of code and the piece of code says
you know palindrome Q of such and such a
thing you know what the intent of the
person who's writing that code was it's
check whether this is a palindrome if
you see instead you know hash equals
equals string reverse of hash you can
you can read what that says but it's if
you understand the intent from seeing
the explicit name of the function it's a
much better situation now what there are
plenty of places where there isn't an
obvious name for the piece of
functionality and then the right thing
to do is just to use the the primitives
that that we have I might mention just
in terms of incremental language
development
I mentioned take smallest and so on
there's a general move towards these
functions that can be given operator
forms so for example things like you
know greater than which is something
very useful in this entity framework
it's also useful elsewhere it's some
it's an operator version of things like
computing whether whether something is
greater than something else oh here's
another one that's kind of useful this
is so this is the thing this is just a
real straightforward thing but it's it's
a useful thing is a text grid this is
kind of like you want to use a
spreadsheet within a notebook
this is how you can just type things in
just like you would instead of a
standard spreadsheet it's really it's
just a specialization of our grid
functionality but it's a convenient
thing and it's kind of it's the number
one reason in our company why people
still use spreadsheets it's because
they're trying to type in tables and
these spreadsheets now they don't have
to do that because of text grid here's
an
example this is a function up to so this
is something where we can say something
like usually if we say take you know
range of 10 and we say take 12 elements
from from from that will just get some
error if we say up to if we say up to 12
what will happen is that and up to is a
general kind of wrapper that's being
introduced into a lot of kinds of
functions that allows you to to get you
you can get up to 12 elements but not
necessarily exactly 12 elements okay
just as an example of the way that
things develop over the years the
function first which was a function
introduced in version 1 of Mathematica
27 years ago the function first just got
a second argument that it's never had
before and so normally you know when you
say first of X Y you'll just get the
first element there the the question is
what happens if you say that well you
get an error usually but you can
actually now put in a second argument
and which is there which deals with the
case where where there's there's no
there's no first element and that's
that's a useful thing okay back just to
this to give some sense of the sort of
the flow of of new functionality here I
might mention some things in 10.2 also
here's an example of something really
trivial in 10.2 that's very useful it's
the it's it's a thing called nothing and
what does nothing do nothing just
disappears and that's useful because you
can take some list like this and you can
say okay I want all the things all the
Y's I just want them to disappear so you
can just do that and it'll disappear
well a lot of other a lot of other kinds
of functionality that we're introduced
in 10.2 let's see if I can bring up the
the 10.2
let's just give a sense of what was new
and 10.2 a lot of a lot of new list
manipulation operations to do with can
weather lists exactly contain other
lists and so on something something very
convenient some things to do with
creating graphs and networks
particularly things like
nearest-neighbor graph that's that's
kind of a nice thing I could say
something like nearest neighbor graph of
let's say well let's just take let's
just take a bunch of random numbers here
so let's say random integer serve size
100 let's take 50 random integers here
and now this will make oh that's really
boring oh I know what I have to do so
let's make for every integer let's make
a graph of the two nearest neighbors to
that random integer so this will this is
this is now forming a graph by just
selecting selecting integers here let me
let me make a few smaller here okay no
that's not interesting either there's
got to be a good way to do this no it's
some anyway so this is this is something
that's so another thing that's
interesting is nest graph so nest graph
is the analog of nest lists but it makes
a graph instead of a list and it's
taking a function and forming the graph
of what happens from in all possible
applications of that of that function
other kinds of things
oh they're simple functions like regular
polygons that's a that's a real trivial
one that's that that's in the category
of ones which were have been idioms for
a long time now we just have a function
that does it in some generality another
thing that was kind of fun that was okay
so another important one in in version
10.1 actually it's it's not it's still
somewhat experimental it's text search
this is something for doing large-scale
text retrieval it's something where you
can build an index
of a multi gigabyte data set and start
doing text searches on it this is
something that is available now on
desktop systems it will soon be also
available in the cloud it's something
which is useful as kind of a front-end
to doing a lot of sophisticated natural
language processing we've had a bunch of
kinds of new functions like text cases
which is a function that will extract
different kinds of entities from from a
piece of text like you can extract all
the countries mentioned in a particular
piece of text and so on I mean we could
for example let's take let's take the
Wikipedia entry for Elephants let's say
and let's go ahead and try and take at
least um see whether this some see
whether we can get this to work um it
says may take a little while to run here
that will try and extract all the
mentions of countries from that I think
it's a fairly long Wikipedia article
there we go okay so this is now
extracting mentions of countries from
this particular Wikipedia article and we
could turn these we could also turn
these into the canonical entities that
correspond to those countries in our
system another thing that that was added
in in 10.2 is a thing we call code
captions one of the issues with warm
language is that it's if you know
English it's it's easy to understand
what the how the code is written because
the the the functions in wolfin language
have names that are based on uncommon
English but if you don't know English it
can take a little bit longer to to
understand and so we added a capability
let's pick one here it's a Korean we
added a capability here to annotate code
actually let's pick a language what's
the language that a bunch of people here
are going to know French Spanish let's
try Spanish okay so so what happens is
now that if you select that then any any
piece of code is now annotated in
oh um any piece of code is now annotated
in Spanish and it's been interesting to
me I I happen to be in China a little
while back and I switch on toad captions
and suddenly people seem to be much more
engaged in any talk that I give um so so
that's it that was it that's a new thing
that that um we're going to have an
increasing number of languages I think
they're about 15 languages so far
available another another thing that
came in 10.2 is clouds submit that's an
interesting function that's something
which submits a job for execution in the
cloud so if you have a large computation
to be done you can submit it to become a
task that is running asynchronously in
the cloud and there are a bunch of other
sort of tasks and mission functions
which are which are coming soon actually
another function sort of interesting and
it's a function called find formula that
came in version 10.2 which is a thing
for symbolically searching for a formula
which is a good fit to data that sort of
follows on find distribution which tries
to find because sort of a symbolic
representation for a distribution of
data that you've you've given it so
another thing that was new in 10.2 is
sort of an interesting function to
understand it's a thing called mail
receiver function so in in our language
there's a notion of an API function so
if I if I deploy an API function let's
say I say you know X is an integer and
the function is going to compute the
integer to the power the integer okay
great so there's an API function now I
can say cloud deploy that and I will get
something which runs as which is a web
api so now I can go here they didn't
give it any arguments but I can say
question mark x equals x equals you know
99 or something here and then I can do
the computation and I'll get back the
result okay so this is running an API
running in the cloud where we're
initiating the execution of the
PII by asking the web server to do this
to go to this URL
okay so there's another different thing
you can do and it's called a mail
receiver function and the idea there is
that instead of causing something to
happen by sending it to a web server
you're causing something to happen by
sending it to a mail server and so what
happens here is that I can say I can
take this thing here and I can say
deploy to a mail receiver so I could say
something like deploy here something
that does the string reverse of hash
subject so what this will do is is it
will make a mail receiver function which
when it is sent when so let me deploy
this what this will do is it will create
an email address here we go receiver
blah blah blah here and if I send email
to that email address then the subject
line of my email will be I'll get the
the the the string reverse of the
subject line of that email so this will
cause something to be executed in in the
cloud as a result of sending email so
for example for somebody like me I'm
building myself all kinds of mail
receiver functions that receive mail
from all sorts of sources and then can
process that mail automatically to do
things
okay well lots of other things that you
know last year we had just released
version 10 point O of our system at the
time of the conference last year ten
point O was a very very big release for
us we released a ten point one a couple
of months after that and it had all
kinds of things in it too I'll just show
you one of them as a function called
angle path and so angle path is kind of
it's like an implementation of something
like logo in ml from language so you can
take an angle path and you can say
graphics of line of angle path and what
this is going to say is it's going to
take a path it's going to take something
where we're
um to do this in this case we are we're
progressively increasing the angle so so
if I take a very small one of these you
can see what's happening where no you
can't see what's happening there well
let's do it let's just do a constant
here let's say table let's do a constant
by the way the one of the new syntax is
if you okay so this is this is now a
table where there's a constant angle
between each successive each successive
element if I for example say let's say I
want some a range of let's say I'm going
to increase I'm going to go from 0 to
200 in steps of 0.1 or something that
will give me progressive increase of the
angle and we get some nice picture like
this this is kind of a a a much more
powerful version of the kind of thing of
thinking about a turtle that's moving
around and the turtle is gradually is
turning at each step this is just a a
power of a power turtle type thing it's
actually also useful for it's
surprisingly common that ones interested
in having some geometrical structure
where were knows that there's some
particular element and then there's
something else that's a certain angle to
that element this is something that
implements that so a big part of the
story of version 10 or part of the story
with version 10 was introducing machine
learning so modern machine learning into
our system and we introduced the
function classify which whose goal is to
basically be able to take arbitrary data
and create an efficient machine learning
classifier that can then be used to to
classify future data the classifier has
been very successful we've been
progressively enhancing it adding
different kinds of methods using machine
learning to learn what kinds of methods
to use for particular kinds of data one
of the things that we did in 10.1 was we
introduced the function image identify
and so what image identify does is some
to take take an image and try and say
what it is and you might have seen in
in May of this year we had a website
which is fundamentally just a single
call for the image identify function but
let me show you that that website so
this is just a deployed version of image
identify and the idea here is we can go
and and take get some picture around in
picture let's go to the web
let's pick come let's look for a picture
of an otter for example and that's some
say we go here okay let's pick a let's
pick one of these let's try that guy
let's move it over here and now that's
cool um and so it will in about 200
milliseconds it will try and tell us
what that thing is let's try another one
here and so okay see if there's
something that's if there's an otter
that's something out there that doesn't
really look like come on there's got to
be something else other than an actual
otter here I don't know it seems like we
have a lot of these so okay good well
now this is also a as I said this is
also a function in the system let's see
if I can move one of these guys in here
sometimes these don't see if that works
yeah there we go
okay so there's an image and now we can
say in here image identify and we will
get okay
the northern river otter okay we can
actually if we want to we can we can ask
it in more detail let's let's say we say
let's use image identify here and that's
some let's let's say we want all
categories and we want the probabilities
for different different things and see
oops that's not want I want let's say
ten of them okay so this is now showing
us for this particular okay so it
decided that the the probability for a
northern river otter is point five four
for a river otter at all is 0.92 there's
sort of a trade-off between specificity
and correctness and so in this
particular that the website actually
made a different choices here than we
made in the in the system here we we
decided to make to go for the more
specific thing even though
didn't have such a high probability of
being for certain right as the more
generic kind of thing okay so so image
identify the fact that image identify
works is really a very impressive thing
it's it's something that you know I I
worked on things like neural networks
back around nineteen eighty or so and I
couldn't really get them to do anything
terribly interesting and now we are
whatever it is thirty five years later
and suddenly you can get neural networks
to do things like recognized in the case
of image identify about ten thousand
different kinds of objects how did this
happen
the basic methods are actually just the
same as they were thirty-five years ago
what's changed as some engineering
tweaks but also computers have gotten a
lot faster and the training sets have
gotten a lot bigger so for example image
identify was trained there about twenty
five million images and it's it was the
original training took many GPU months
to do we've now made it much faster to
do training the the thing that sort of
interesting the the you know what what's
happening is we're reaching kind of a
it's impressive to humans because humans
do about the same number they're about
5,000 or so picture balloons common
nouns in English ten thousand kinds of
objects is is really good for a person
to be able to recognize so it's
impressive to people when we have a sort
of an AI ish machine that can recognize
ten thousand kinds of things the fact
that we're able to do that now is pretty
much a consequence of the fact of the
scale of our systems is comparable to at
least it sits within the same with the
same ballpark as human visual processing
and I think that's why we're now able as
of sort of this year to achieve these
kinds of successes and things like
visual image recognition it's sort of
interesting there been a bunch of
companies mostly that have tried to
bring out image identifies in the last
year or so based on the sort of new
technology I think ours seems to be
somewhat better than anybody else's the
main reason is partly some cleverness in
the actual machine learning part of it
but much more importantly a lot of
use of curation and data curation image
curation and so on in providing the
right kind of training and making the
right kinds of decisions about things
like specificity versus correctness and
so on in what comes out and so it's kind
of a an extension of the the
long-running experience that we've had
in doing data curation now in addition
to curating data that is textual or
numerical we're curating image data and
that's been important for making an
image identify that really works well
and we're progressively so we just done
cars we should now be able to identify
lots of kinds of cars I think that's now
in the system if it isn't already it
will be by in the next week or so we're
doing we just did lots of types of food
that's interesting because it allows you
to do sort of automatic nutrition
computations and there are a lot of
specialized image identifies that people
have been interested in us building for
all sorts of different kinds of things
from fishes to beetles to consumer
products and so on and this is something
that has really become an interesting
interesting business actually I might
say that one thing that's coming soon
very soon we thought it was going to be
in 10.3 but it didn't quite make it
there is a completely user a way where
where users can build an image identify
at least as good as our image identify
and so that's being made possible
because we have a thing we call a net
function net function is a thing that
implements known that like system it has
about 35 different kinds of layer types
for doing convolutional neural networks
and recurrent neural networks and all
the different zoos of sort of special
functions of the neural network world so
net function is the thing that takes a
given piece of data runs it through a
neuron Network gets the results there's
also a function net train that takes a
net function and a bunch of training
data and goes off and trains the net
function adjusts all the weights in the
neural network to to be able to train it
and what you'll be able to do is to say
cloud submit of net train of something
with some giant data set and it will go
off for some number of hours and train
and train that net function and then
you'll get a train net function that you
can then use just like you can use
classifier function in classify and I
think that will be a quite powerful
thing for people to be able to do well
okay so it's it's worth remembering in
version 10 last year what one things
that's happened is we keep on adding
kind of new frameworks to our language
so for example associations this is an
example of an association here these
were just added in version 10 and
they've already become really quite
central to a lot of things that we're
doing in our system another thing just
added was data set which is our way of
handling kind of symbolic generalization
of relational and no SQL databases that
is has become a really powerful way to
do data science in our system well okay
so I talked a little bit about some some
of the things that have come in in the
last year of sort of specific things in
the last year of Rd this is actually
what I've talked about so far is only
really the small tip of a much bigger
iceberg and let me I think I have to
speed up here let me let me talk about
some some of the some of the rest of the
iceberg it's really a lot of it is about
Ryoka texting pretty much everything
that we that we do and let's see the
kind of the the core of what we're doing
is centers around Wolfram language and
often language is is what we sort of get
by taking all of those years of
development of Mathematica putting it
together with all of the things that
we've done for from alpha together with
our cloud and those things put together
make Wolfram language which has now
become the foundation for everything we
do including for example Mathematica and
in in general you know we've been widely
known and used in in kind of education
and research and so on for many years
one of the things that people for
example at these conferences are always
pointing out to us as we're not as
widely used in mains
dream production as we somehow should be
given all the computation capabilities
that we have one of the things that we
set out to change a number of years ago
is is that and we're getting really
close to to to being able to do that
we've been one of the things we've
really been emphasizing with Wolfram
language is deploying all of the kinds
of computation capabilities that we have
got and I'll talk a bit about the the
kind of different channels for
deployment that we now have and sort of
the idea here is to be able to get our
technology stack to be able to be used
as as deeply as possible all across the
all across the kind of technology world
and I think the the result of this is is
kind of a a remarkable set of
opportunities it's it's a lot of
technology that we've been building for
a great many years and a lot of
technology that many of you have also
invested a lot in and I think the
exciting thing is that this is now going
to be very much opened up and able to be
used much more broadly all over the
technology world and it's something
where it's pretty nice that all this new
stuff that all the stuff that we've
built and many of you have built over
the years all the books that are written
all these kinds of things it's all going
to be able to be much more widely used
and integrated and it's exciting to see
this happen now I mean there are there
are a number of frustrations that remain
I mean the the biggest the number one
frustration is that we're not quite
ready with all of these great deployment
channels we're really really close in
fact we'd hoped by the time of this
conference to be able to show some of
the more some of the sort of the the the
leading edge of these kinds of
deployment channels I'll show you some
previews of things probably in a just a
matter of a couple of weeks a large part
of sort of our new deployment channels
will be we'll be ready at least in beta
form and by probably early next year
they'll be ready in in final form that's
sort of frustration number one
frustration number two is that the more
we the more we build in terms of our
technology stack the further the gap is
between what the world seems to
understand that we have
and what we've actually built and so
this is something which I'm hoping I'm
hoping that some of the community that
includes a lot of you guys can can help
somewhat with this process of trying to
take this big technology stack that
we've all invested a lot in and make it
more accessible to people well okay so
let's sum let's take a look at some of
the things that we are doing let me see
how does not it where is I am looking
for that's definitely out it um no here
we go um so this will be the some
version of this will be the new homepage
for our company a little while and it
kind of illustrates a number of things
so there's so other stuff we're doing
but an important piece of this is kind
of immediate access to our technology
and I want to talk about some of what
what's there one of the things so for
many years now we have been working to
develop a cloud version of of everything
we do this has been a very it's always
difficult when there's sort of a major
change in platform in the world
we've for those of you who remember
version 3 of mathematical and version 6
of Mathematica these were both rather
rather complex and turbulent times
because they got both correspondents at
times when there was sort of major
changes than the in the platforms that
we got to to use to to run what we had
well the cloud is another such change
it's been a think the cloud is also
probably the worst the most jungle-like
of development environments for for
software that I've seen in 35 years of
being involved in software development
so it's been quite a challenge to get
everything we do to actually work in the
cloud but it does now
it's kind of it's kind of nice that you
can go to a you can go to a just a pure
web browser and you can be doing all
those things that you do in ordinary
well from notebooks and you can just be
doing them right here in the cloud you
can you can without without doing any
without having any plugins or anything
like that you can just be doing things
directly in a in a web browser well one
of the things that is coming very soon
is what we call our open cloud which is
a way where people can basically just go
straight to the open cloud just a web
page and start doing computations with
Wolfram language they don't even have to
register or login or anything it's kind
of like wolf malphur you just go there
and start doing stuff and we see this as
being an important step because it's
kind of opening up the the capabilities
of our computation capabilities so so
that anybody can can start using them
that there's a there's you can't save
stuff in the open cloud you can't
there's a lot of stuff you can't do in
the open cloud but you can get started
in doing computations in sort of the
same way that wolf malphur lets you get
started doing computations well there
too two things will be available in the
open cloud wolfram development platform
more from programming lab there'll be
others available later the open code as
I say it's just sort of the beginning of
access to those those systems there's a
there's a long sequence of things beyond
what you can get in the in the in the
pure open cloud but let me talk a little
bit about development platform a
programming lab so well from development
platform is it's all about doing doing
software development it's intended for
people who want to take Wolfram language
and use it to create production software
and the thing that's exciting about
Wolfram language is because of all of
the it's a it's a knowledge-based
language where we've tried to build in
it's the world's only knowledge-based
language where we've sort of had the
philosophy of building in as much
capability directly into the language as
possible and that's what we've been
doing for
last close to 30 years and the the this
sort of the other part of it is trying
to automate as much as we can trying to
make it so that basically when you have
an idea when you have some sort of
algorithm concept it becomes as
automatic as possible to get that
algorithm concept implemented within
Wolfram language well welcome
development platform is the way to take
that sort of concept and make it into a
production piece of software as
efficiently as possible and so the the
primary thing people will do a
development platform is create pieces of
Wolfram language code code and then
deploy them to make web apps mobile apps
and so on